c'est la consternation cet après midi au
théâtre sa ville une fusillade a éclaté
aux environs de 16 heures des coups de
feu ont retenti à l'angle des rues émile
zola et robespierre
mais ici c'est le règne de l'omerta peu
de gens ont voulu témoigner j'ai entendu
les coups de feu et a sauté par la
fenêtre après egée après j'ai vu le
match et cote à terre voilà j'allais
chez un couturier là et alors là c'est
le couturier j'ai entendu des coups de
feu
plusieurs coups de feu donc j'ai
continué après en revenant j'ai entendu
quelqu'un you you tube là la direction
de la police et le procureur sont très
vite sur place pour évaluer la situation
en l'état actuel des investigations
il apparaît que les un équipage de la
bac il de fort-de-france a aperçu un
individu qui était activement recherché
dans le cadre de faits extrêmement
graves qui lui sont reprochés que
lorsqu'ils ont voulu procéder à son
interpellation il apparaît en l'état
actuel et l'individu se soit retourné et
fait usage de son arme en direction d'un
fonctionnaire de police qui a alors été
blessés ils sont ensuite que les uns des
fonctionnaires de police et fait usage
de même deux lors de leurs armes qui a
touché également l'individu lequel était
également a été également blessées les
deux
le fonctions de police ainsi que
l'individu ainsi qu'ils étaient
recherchés ont été transportés à
l'hôpital afin d'être soigné très vite
sur les réseaux sociaux une vidéo des
instants qui ont suivi la fusillade a
circulé on y voit le policier blessé
ainsi que l'individu au sol
une enquête est ouverte pour déterminer
les circonstances exactes de cette
fusillade qui après le meurtre de volga
plage vient s'ajouter à la violence qui
gangrène ce quartier de fort de france